Once you've identified
your top few advantages,
there are a few frameworks
you can use to outline them.
We're going to use a grid to map all
your competitors on one slide and
position you as the leader.
You're going to create something
like this for your final project.
Let's start by focusing on two
things that you really excel at.
These are your competitive advantages.
We'll use these to label
the two axes of the grid.
And we want you to place
your main competitors here.
But again, you'll be positioned as
the leader, right in this area.
These competitive advantages
can be price versus value,
or you can write a specific
value to your customer.
Maybe think of something
that your potential users or
investors would be really,
really interested in, or excited about.
So we'll have to name our
two axes accordingly.
So if it's price,
it will be low price and high price.
Now let's say our value is innovation.
We can have high innovation and
low innovation.
Or you can choose something else.
So for specific and generic,
let's talk about this.
For Embarkment we started to realize
that the general market was a bit
crowded.
So we needed to find a unique value to
differentiate our app from, let's say,
a dog kennel.
So we decided to focus
on a niche market.
And go the same idea, but only for
fancy dogs with the most refined tastes.
We're going to offer high end services.
We'll only accept sitters who have
nice homes and nice backyards.
Those sitters must take the dogs
on multiple walks a day.
And the sitters must only offer
the highest quality food and care for
the dogs.
For the more refined of Embarkment, we
chose a grid that includes one axis for
quality, let's change that now.
One axis for quality, so
we have high quality and low quality,
and we're going to keep the specific and
generic axis.
So now that we have our grid,
we're going to choose competitors from
the product form category, so
these are our direct competitors.
And we might also find a few
other relevant competitors.
So we have the local kennel,
which is pretty generic.
And the quality's not great, but
sometimes they're associated with vets,
so that's good.
Then we have The Dog House, which is
more specific because they only take
dogs, but they're not as specific as we
are, and the quality's not super great.
The don't really vet their sitters.
Then we have Doggie Vacay,
which they are pretty good quality but
they're not as specific as we are.
And finally we have Rover,
who also has great quality,
but they're more generic than we are.
So notice that we're here in
the top right-hand quadrant.
This is the best place to be, and
it really sets us apart from
all of our other competitors.